hello my name is jehon marku and my
presentation is entitled vaping risks
and product safety i am the
editor-in-chief of the american journal
of endocannabinoid medicine
for those of you who aren't familiar
with my work i've been studying cannabis
and cannabinoids for about 15
years in academia in the private sector
as well as working on regulations and
standards for this industry
so today what i'm going to talk about is
a little bit of an update about the
vaping crisis
and product safety around that and some
of the things we've learned
and for those of you who may not
remember this from last year
i'm going to share with you my test that
i use to
quickly catch up and that's called the
meme test is what are people
saying out there memes are sort of the
mirror for which we can see what's going
on in society
and social media is actually a fair game
for looking at
health outcomes and public health risks
we'll talk about what are the risks and
associations of different
products in this space the additives
factors
you know overview of some of the stats
from the last few months and there's
been a big
update as the curve
for the lung injuries associated with
divali and vaping injuries have
flattened and part of the reason that is
flattened is
as of february the cdc stopped tracking
non-hospitalized visits and we'll talk
about how that has impacted the data a
little bit
um we'll end with talking about the
anatomy of vape pens what are they
how are vaporizers being used in
clinical
therapeutic studies and future
directions
so if you look on social media
and start to peruse sort of the public
perception of vaping and how people are
handling it
it really kind of runs the gamut um
there are people who are making a lot of
home devices
that sometimes defy common sense
when we think about people chronically
consuming this you may be thinking of a
tiny little device but one of the
biggest
issues that wasn't widely discussed in
over the last year was the diy crowd is
that there's a huge
groups of people who like to make their
own
vapes um and that's one of the reasons
a lot of vape apps are no longer in the
apple store
is because a lot of them are used to
help people build
vapes safely and check resistance and
voltage meters and things like that
but in addition to the dui there's also
people misusing
these vapes and you can find all sorts
of videos of people
inhaling them and sending the stream
through their noses and ears and things
like that that these devices probably
weren't doing um
also um people's perception of this is
like yeah
who would have thought that you know
inhaling chemicals into your lungs could
be dangerous
but on the other side of that people are
saying well while the fda and other
agencies say they don't know these
ingredients
many of the ingredients in these devices
are fall under the purview of the fda
some
are even grass for oral consumption not
for inhalation
but we have this issue where we have
people
doing whatever they want building their
own devices people using devices in the
market in
ways they weren't intended and then
confusion about
what we know about what's in these
ingredients
and on top of that some people just see
this as an evil thing
you know the reason why it's called
evali this we'll get to is is not
by chance i'm pretty sure that was an
intentional thing to kind of label this
as an evil thing
but there's a lot of people who say that
this is what they do instead of smoking
cigarettes or smoking cannabis you know
we talk about vaping we're talking about
both nicotine
and cannabis products and a lot of
people
at least subjectively anecdotally say
their lives are
improved by not smoking cigarettes
instead using vaporizers
but not all vaporizers are created equal
and
while these seem extreme there's even
ones that are even more extreme
my favorite that i found on twitter is
almost like a fake advertisement you
know tired of non
non-toxic cannabis well do we have the
thing for you big mystery sticks
something patented that we can't tell
you about with lots of chemicals
um and you know what they're not listed
on the package sometimes
i mean that's true for products that
aren't regulated that is products that
aren't sold by
licensed operators
so here's a brief history about
electronic cigarettes at least in the
cannabis space the first
proto e-cigarettes were actually
introduced in the early 90s
and didn't really start to rise in
popularity to the late 90s and 2000s but
they were
really strongly introduced in about 2007
into the u.s cannabis market
and again several cannabis derived
products on the market
can be vaporized and cannabis oil hash
oil extracts
skyrocketed in popularity because there
was now an efficient and discreet way to
start to use these products
that didn't involve you know blow
torches and setting things on fire
to consume it if you don't know what i'm
talking about
you can find plenty of information about
that on the net
meanwhile colorado and washington state
see their sales
skyrocketing of these devices and up
until this vape crisis
um it's estimated that you know hundreds
of millions
of these devices vape pens for cannabis
were sold
some estimates say over 200 million
before we started seeing
issues uh with lung injuries
so this is a little timeline of the vape
crisis starting in
2018 um there were starting to be some
documentations of hospitalizations from
cbd vapes um people were
um to be fair it was not the cbd in
these vapes it was these synthetic drugs
and other additives that were in them
that were leading to these
hospitalizations
however there also started to be a build
up in 2018 up until august
of cases of vaping-related illness not
just from thc products but nicotine
products and in august 23rd
after build up over the summer the first
reported death
in illinois and this followed a lot of
reports about associations with the
thc containing products we'll talk a
little bit about the former fda
commissioner scott gottlieb
um wrote a washington post uh editorial
which he um basically
was able to said some very interesting
things
which caused some panic um both in the
industry
and public and in the media and as we
start to see more and more
issues the sixth death reported in
september
by september we're starting to see
states ban all flavoring agents
the fda is announcing criminal probes we
see a
cbd supplier facing guilty charges to to
injuring people in utah
and virginia uh with products that were
contaminated
obviously massachusetts temporarily ban
all products
and culminating basically in the fda
saying don't use thc
vapes even though it's really only
products on the illicit market
or products that weren't meeting safety
standards i mean the cdc then targeted
vitamin e acetate as one of the main
culprits
but it yet does not explain all the
symptoms of
the vaping issue with a long illness the
part of what's difficult about a volley
is that it's not just from one thing it
really can be from
anything that damages your lungs that
leads to hospitalization associated with
vaping
so uh the former commissioner of the fda
who
um stopped being commissioner in april
2019 right when this crisis was starting
to
uh gain traction said you know bright
lines must be drawn between less harmful
ingredients and those that cause
undue risk that would arm regulators
with information to crack down on
illegal
and dangerous vapes
and he also said it's time to end the
political ambivalence that allows thc
and cbd to evade oversight and some of
this stuff is a little tongue-in-cheek
because there are a lot of regulations
and states
that regulate these products and there
seemed to be some confusion even at the
fda of
where the issue was coming from again it
largely seemed to be with
illicit manufacturers manufacturers
in gray areas unlicensed manufacturing
distribution of these products
the acting fda chief also said that
you know we're this is a top priority
for the fda they're working tirelessly
to gather information
and by the time we hit october we
started to see
a lot of these cases decreasing and
decreasing and decreasing
so where are we now well um
currently the cdc is no longer reporting
uh this is only reporting hospitalized
cases associated with
um vaping injuries the uh vaping product
used associated lung injury
so what that means is that prior numbers
were including all cases and
non-hospitalized cases have been removed
from
all previously reported data that the
cdc had on the website
so um while we thought that there were
many thousands of uh life-threatening
issues with these cases there was about
2 800 as
of this year the most current website
today
is of february 18 2020
and there has been 68 confirmed deaths
with the average age of
about 49 or 50 years old and as you can
see from the little map
where you have the dark blue and dark
green we see the most uh
cases so texas stands out new york
as well
um so so what is the risk
here so what how can you protect
yourself in this sort of confused
confusing era well it's the same as it's
always been
it should avoid inhaling
substances from inexpensive disposable
type
hardware a lot of the sources of injury
largely include overwhelmingly include
do-it-yourself
manufacturing crowd illicit gray and
unregulated markets
actual vaporizers such as herbal
vaporizers are in no way associated with
a valet
or lipoid pneumonia which was one of the
things associated with vitamin e acetate
leading to the hospitalization
exposure to really sort of any sort of
aerosol
can have significant rents especially if
it's heated
so a lot of times you see this coughs
and shortness of breath
associated with this and again the
diagnosis of this
ranges from any sort of kind of lung
issue you have
a sonophilic pneumonia lipoid pneumonia
organizing pneumonia of respiratory
bronchitis
and these sorts of things and sometimes
mechanical ventilation
is required as sort of a lung protective
strategy
so we're just going to talk about lipoid
pneumonia a little bit because this is
actually
something um we understand a little bit
about
and however it does not explain all of
the hospitalizations in all the cases
but it is of was a focus of the fda
investigation
so this is basically inflammation um due
to foreign
lipid-like material that the lungs can
effectively clear or break down
leads to compromised air exchange you
know your
your lungs have a very special tissue
and when you put layers of stuff down
there it affects not only
the lungs ability to expand and contract
and move
but also the distance of which
you know oxygen has to diffuse through
and if you put a
layer there it makes it very difficult
and this is also difficult
condition to diagnose
so when it comes to liploid pneumonia
what's
interesting is up until recently there
were only a
few case reports associated with
e-cigarettes over the last 10 years
now which is very surprising because up
until
the vape crisis last year there were
hundreds of millions
of vape products sold
in the u.s alone so
there can be aspiration of other things
that cause lipoitemid
and this has been documented for mineral
oil paraffin and even kerosene
less commonly reported but have been
reported
lipoid pneumonia has come from
accidentally inhaling milk
poppy seed oil egg yolks using spray
paint
cleaning oil containing vats siphoning
diesel fuel long-term use of potentium
jelly long-term use of wsd40
etc and um one of my favorite
case reports is actually the excessive
use of chapstick lip balm and lip gloss
have
been associated with developing lipoid
pneumonia as well
so the purpose of this slide is just let
you know that
vaping did not create a new illness
a lot of these vape you know lipoid
pneumonia and other conditions
have been around for a while
how long you say great question so i
guess this is some of the audience
participation is
um when do you think the first case
report
of lipoid pneumonia was ever published
so 2019
2018 and 60s 1930s
or 1890s even um
well if you said a you're wrong
you said b c you're wrong if you said d
you are correct so everyone who got that
wrong i want to see you after this
powerpoint
for a brief discussion about your
progress
just something one of my professors
would say and so here's the reference
from the american journal of nursing on
one of the
the earliest case of lipoid pneumonia
that i could find
so what are these products
that uh people are using they come in
many shapes
sizes and disguises but essentially
they consist of a battery a heating
element
and a chamber a reservoir for a liquid
to go through
so the liquid sits in a reservoir passes
through
a heating element atomizer that then
comes out a mouthpiece
fairly straightforward where it gets a
little
tricky is in um
the actual performance of these devices
their performance is all over the place
and the less expensive they are the less
reliable they are
you may be surprised that in less
expensive devices
you may put down a button and it might
be one temperature one time and then
100 degrees hotter the next you really
have no idea
about the thermoregulation of some of
these devices which can lead to
unpredictable
outcomes and another issue here is that
it's also very difficult to
dilute cannabinoids
safely when you if you want you know
cannabis oil is very sticky it's not
made to flow through
nicotine delivery devices and so it has
to be
diluted if you dilute it too much you
then have to add
things to make it thicker so that it
doesn't leak
and it's in this we see really dilute
products
that are mostly excipients and
that will lead to issues down the line
potentially
if they're overheated so how can you
tell
if you have a true vaporizer or not
there's a simple one and this is from a
colleague dr russo's
2016 article you know everybody loves
advice that rhymes so if it's red hot
then vaping it's not
and so this is not a vaping device
that red hot coal is burning the
material i spoke to a combustion chemist
that worked to rj reynolds and
the most technical term for this is
smoldering
where you take something and you
basically put it against a red hot coal
that sets it on fire you do get
some micro vaporization but
overwhelmingly things are getting burned
by this device there are true vaporizers
that have been approved and used in
clinical studies
among them the volcano has been used in
a clinical study notably by dr donald
abrams and hiv aids patients
pax i'm just a disclaimer i'm on their
health advisory board
they also have devices in a clinical
trial
for example at ucsf looking at different
ratios of cannabinoids
so there are safe devices out there that
go through incredible pains to make
their devices safe
efficient reliable and even use them in
clinical studies
so this tocopherol vitamin e that's
found in
vape devices um you know it's not found
in cannabis but it's found in high
levels of many products associated with
hospitalization
it's an oily substance that's very
common in foods and skin care products
it's actually
generally regarded as safe by the fda
for oral consumption
and what's weird is that actually some
studies have looked at the benefits of
vitamin e
inhalation from various conditions
but there are now guideline compliance
studies or clinical trials to
demonstrate the safety
of vitamin e to a significant degree
and what makes it an issue
and we'll talk about towards the end of
this presentation
is that there are different forms of
tocopherol different versions different
isomers
and they have different effects on
inflammation so
if you're using a very inexpensive not
for human consumption
to cough for all vitamin e preparation
in your devices
you're probably going to have a lot of
compounds in there that are going to
complicate the toxicology risk
assessment
so again while tocopherol acetate
is likely to have similar systemic
effects to vitamin e
there might be some curveballs there so
once it gets in your lungs
if it got on your lungs and it stayed
there everyone was the same
we'd see a lot more cases
of hospitalization but our lungs
of express proteins um which help to
break down things that get in there
notably the sips right there there our
liver also has these for breaking down
drugs and other substances but these are
in
our lungs as well and
one of the best hypotheses i've heard is
actually an
old one which said that you know people
have different versions of these enzymes
which
affect their sensitivities to drugs if
they also have those in the lung
it might mean that individuals
metabolize
tocopherol differently in their lungs
some people can clear it out right away
some people can't and this is a genetic
factor
which basically means you either get a
really good copy of the protein that's
really great at
chewing up vitamin e or you got a slower
coffee that's not so great
at doing but it's believed that vitamin
acetate
can cause lipoid pneumonia in some
individuals if their metabolic
capability is not sufficient in the
lungs
the last thing about vitamin e
is that you know up until you know since
about 1971
until this you know issue started there
are really only two cases of lipoid
pneumonia
um associated with vitamin e um
which which is very surprising given how
wide spread it is you know
people cook with it um right but again
there's not
despite people cooking with a lot of
vitamin e and being exposed to it
several hours a day you think
of a sous chef or someone who's frying
foods all day
they're getting exposed to that stuff
but there really is no publicly
available data regarding the heat
degradation of these products
um but it's unlikely that you know
acutely or systemically
toxic at low doses so you know it's
probably a good sign that chefs
aren't getting lipoid pneumonia from
cooking with
tocopherols um
and again one of the biggest issues
could be that
you know at a certain temperature maybe
these
you know vitamin e isn't as dangerous
isn't it as risky than when it's at an
exceedingly high temperature in a poorly
controlled devices that leads to
producing
all these other compounds and those
other
compounds kind of bring us to our next
section
here we're going to wrap up the vitamin
e and talk about terpenes
to to finish this presentation so again
tocopherol acetate will
focus does not explain the entire
crisis it was detected
in almost all the fluid samples they
tested in lungs but not in all the
products
that caused the illness again
you know agencies have reiterated that
this
compound was not detected in all samples
associated with the volley
medium chain triglycerides seemed to be
the lowest one of the lower risk
additives for these devices terpenes and
other agents are
significant factors but again i'd like
to just stress that this vitamin e
hypothesis does not explain many of the
symptoms that people are explaining
given that we have controlled studies
looking at vitamin e and inhalation
from the 90s
and once and why do i say vitamin e
doesn't
really explain the whole vape crisis
well
in order to get the gastrointestinal
effects for example that are
that is one of the main symptoms of a
volley um
you'd have to consume about a thousand
you know milligrams
through vaping through inhalation and
even a
you know cannabis aficionado that's not
a challenge to anyone who uses cannabis
but you know you couldn't expect someone
to consume more than a couple hundred
milligrams of oil per day in one of
these devices
so this suggests that there are
additives or other contaminants
contributing maybe pesticides heavy
metals
flavorings are issues again also
associated with concentrated
products so this is a great slide
cursely of my colleague
brad douglas at the workshop and why i
like this slide
is because it had lists all these
terpenes in cannabis but also was
their chemical identifying number and
this is very important because
not all crop lane is created equal not
all limiting is created equal you want
to make sure you're getting the right
compound at the right purity for the
proper
use um because you might be getting
some of these compounds you know alpha
versus beta pine you know they have
isomers they have different versions
they have different isomers and this is
very important i think consideration we
think about purity and flavoring of
compounds
there are problematic flavoring agents
these don't
uh suppose i know naturally occur in
cannabis but they are used
dye is teal this one is a creamy
flavoring agent
that is associated with a lot of issues
and i would say should probably be
avoided
at all costs acetaldehyde
as well is something that's commonly
seen but these again
are some problematic the ones
highlighted in yellow are
ones i suggest avoiding at all costs
so as you're going through this
information
and then trying to be safe out there i
think it's important to distinguish
between flower
and concentrate vape devices they do not
pose the same risks
especially if you're using let's call it
expensive vaporizers
and expensive flower vaporizers in two
separate clinical studies
have showed improved lung function in
patients
and this might be because they stop
smoking and we're using a vaporizer
again there's a clinical trial that i
think is still recruiting right now
at ucsf looking at different ratios
of thc and cbd in a flower vaping device
you know and again when we talk about
you know high temperatures propylene
glycol
vegetable glycerin these decompose
generating
potentially harmful compounds um
and uh you know it's it's thought that
um you know smoking some of this stuff
could represent about
uh a smoking session but it basically
fights about one percent of your daily
exposure limit for things like
aldehydes or formaldehyde from using a
device
uh an expensive device that's chock full
of excipients
um and compounds like that so there's a
couple other things to think in mind
to keep in mind is as you're navigating
vapes
again important to distinguish between
herbal vaporizers
high-end devices and e-cigarette
disposable type devices
want some are more reliable some are
made with great pains to be compliant
with regulations
others are not
one interesting hypothesis i have is
that the trade war may have exacerbated
this situation so about this time last
year there was a trade war going on with
china
and it may have led to um less reliable
parts and pieces and devices
where all of these vape products come
from coming from
um from as an indirect cost of the trade
wars there's less quality available
what would have been helpful was to and
was to have a robust response that
analyzed products before and after the
crisis
we really have not seen this like what
changed in the supply
that causes because again hundreds of
millions of these products were sold
before there were real any secret
reports about these
products again remember that a lot of
companies go through great pains to be
compliant with health and safety
regulations and product safety standards
and those are the ones
who you you should support um gray
market cbd vapes are a concern
and show more if not the same issues as
thc vapes
and this has been since 2015 actually a
i'm not going to name
names but a cbd producer gave out cbd
vape pens
at a celebrity awards show at hollywood
and in everyone's gift bags and those
were full of not only
some of the nasty things we mentioned
earlier but also synthetic
drugs as well and
a few years later that person who was in
charge
whose products were for the poster child
for the vape
crisis uh is looking at jail time
always think about hardware issues
disposal which versus cheap versus
expensive
and again perceptions of what the fda
says when fda says something is safe
it's usually within
narrow parameters so just because the
fda
says something is safe doesn't mean it's
safe by any means
necessary of consuming it so a lot of
things are approved
orally you know for oral consumption by
the fda doesn't mean that they're safe
through every route um and always
temper your understanding of the vape
crisis by
remembering that there's a huge
unstudied population out there of
do-it-yourself vape enthusiasts who are
building their
own devices and these you know there's
reports of these exploding
of people getting hurt with these
processes from not
doing it correctly
and so to sum up everything it seems
that
the vape crisis was largely an issue
with unregulated markets
and in the dyi vape enthusiast crowd
health officials consider rampant hidden
adulteration
the greatest risk associated with vaping
cbd products as opposed to consuming it
in
any other form industry
needs to act it needs to have chemical
inventories lists of additives that are
natural versus those that are not
provide resources to regulators
establish independent expert panels
um it seemed like a lot of the industry
sort of stuck their head in the sand to
wait for this to
pass this is an example of things that i
think the cannabis industry would
continue to face
safety of their products backing up
claims
and i think is going to be really
important as we move towards
increasingly tighter and tighter
regulations
so thank you all so much i encourage you
to check out
the american journal of endocannabinoid
medicine it's a free
public access journal and you can go to
the website ajendomed.com
here are covers of our last two issues
i'm happy to answer any questions and
feel free to send me an email
thank you